it's another busy day for aspiring
politician Susannah caravan ski she's
preparing for a special campaign trail
appointment Christopher Street day and
leipzig caravan ski and her campaign
team will be attending the annual gay
pride parade to hand out flyers toys and
other goodies the candidates motto
politics should be fun windows Tigers
head people tend to associate the
Parliament with hot air and old fogies
but politics can fascinate people to
think is almighty McNaughton swing
condos when it can be enjoyable with
your kind of fun is definitely part of
it for me what a fascist saying stinker
discover dr. sweet young colorful and
lively that's how the Left Party
presents itself at the festival
candidates want to be known as the fun
party in the bundestag it's a very young
party only founded in 2007 it's an
events like these where the party wants
to promote a coolant up feed-image
canavan ski and her team are here to win
new voters and new party members for the
33 year old graduate and cultural
studies and political science working
for the Left Party is a labor of love
except for fela nedderman I meant a lot
of nice people people who are involved
who it's fun to do projects and write
material with that's why I stuck with it
because of the human contact topless
maid inventions for 20 wins Emma there
was a distinct lack of fun at the left
parties annual conference a year ago
there's unity on the surface but the
east-west divine within the party is a
big issue
the party was formed from the successor
to the Communist Party that ruled East
Germany and disillusioned Social
Democrats primarily from the West the
conference produced a new relatively
young leadership duo but the party is
struggling in surveys and the average
age of a Left Party member is 60 so the
party have high hopes for younger
activists like Susanna Caravan ski and
Misha bhagwat sit here on the campaign
trail in northern Saxony their aim is to
give the party a new image and give this
struggling region a voice the left
hemisphere Susanna supports genuine
grassroots local government something
she wants to bring to the national
parliament can getting the cold eminence
she wants to reconnect the established
olive garden Berlin who were out of
touch with the people I'm she was not
working about it'll harden with in
particular she wants politicians to
reconnect with those on the bottom rungs
of society's ladder Caravan ski visits a
food bank in the town of torgul it has a
team of 30 volunteers supplying up to a
thousand people in need with food
donated by both individuals and
companies people here want to see
caravan ski campaigning for a minimum
wage in Berlin if she's elected soon
this is it's good that organizations
like this exist but I'm angry that
they're necessary the people have so
little money that they can't feed their
families properly it's the government's
fault that they don't have enough money
zalga da fatigue justice gates
absolutely a question that needs raising
in the bundestag it's a question of
sharing the wealth sharing the wealth is
at the top of the left party's agenda
and for Susanna Caravan ski the divide
is not just between rich and poor but
also between urban and rural communities
Augsburg is one of many villages in this
neglected region lacking funds for
social projects while she can't promise
money for this community center she does
promise her commit
must be here does maggie nakatsu this
multi-generational community center
gives you an insight into the problems
here the doofolice of finland onus is
closed it's a grassroots issues as a
condition you can't just turn a blind
eye to it and go back to the city
caravan ski wants to represent the
constituency around torgul if the
bundestag is an ivory tower it's one
from where she's determined to keep
sight of local problems it's a message
she wants to get across to as many of
the 180,000 voters in northern Saxony as
possible Christopher Street day in
Leipzig is an ideal stage for that
commitment her general message of equal
opportunities is about rich and poor
young and old and straight and gay the
prospective member of parliament is out
to transform the political landscape of
Germany
the Venice is it all debts encode nah
you can't get it done in one summer
summer sun and then socialism right
after it's not that easy but I think
we're moving step by step towards the
overall goal of the big two important
gunnison the weather played along for
this party at least just how many votes
susanna caravan skis personal parade
will winner will be clear until Election
Day on the twenty-second at September